attacking a country's economy
the use of sanctions is a way to hit
your adversary where it hurts in the
pocket it's something to do
right short of
going to war as russia faces an
international effort to pile on the
pressure without using direct military
means let's look at how sanctions have
been used in the past and their impact
there has been a huge economic downturn
and then there's the damage that is done
to civil society to a society writ large
in this video we'll ask whether
sanctions actually work when you impose
sanctions affects the people
but it doesn't give a way out
to the situation i think the
sanctions tend to radicalize the status
quo and look at the creative ways that
countries are finding to get around them
china and russia
have
for a very long time and quite willfully
i believe deliberately helped north
korea to circumvent the sanctions
now that russia is facing its own
torrent of restrictions from the rest of
the world what can we expect
find out on business beyond so let's
start with the basics
what are sanctions
well the term covers a whole range of
measures in organization like the united
nations or european union or a single
country can take against the government
citizens or businesses of another
country
the aims of economic sanctions can be
pretty large
right
but at the end of the day
what you're attempting to do
is to coerce
another state
to change its behavior in some
fundamental way
sanctions come in all kinds of forms
including bank account freezes
travel bans
restrictions on selling certain goods to
a country like weapons
or on buying certain goods from them
like oil and gas
they are a powerful tool and in a way it
is a step forward after the diplomatic
tools fail right but it's a step
behind a military action so it's
something in the middle
and in a way is to avoid a military
conflict or try to avoid the military
conflict
and also
try to send a message
to other countries sanctions are just
one tool in the coercion toolbox
alongside diplomacy and of course use of
your armed forces and the use of
sanctions in recent years has shown that
they are a tool when used right that can
cut deep there's a perception that um
economic statecraft or coercive economic
statecraft um
you know
is less harmful
right
less bloodshed uh and that's true that's
true in the sense that bullets aren't
flying and people aren't dying uh but
there are
real effects um real economic effects
that um
[Music]
that touch on on people's lives
no country has felt the impact of
international sanctions more severely
than the pariah state of north korea
north korea has been under trade
sanctions from the u.s since the korean
war way back in the 1950s but it's in
the 21st century that the international
community has turned up the heat the
main aim to end north korea's
development of nuclear weapons
the country you know conducted its first
nuclear test in 2006. and
subsequently the u.n security council
began to impose initially targeted
financial sanctions we've had six other
resolutions since then
those have progressively imposed an arms
embargo
bans on certain north korean exports
including coal minerals and believe it
or not food
they export seafood
exports of north korean forced laborers
and then finally and most importantly
limits on north korean finance and use
of the financial system that's joshua
stanton he's an attorney and he helped
the united states congress to formulate
the u.s sanctions against north korea
over its nuclear programme and alleged
crimes against humanity what these
really add up to
uh are
there is really no official bilateral
trade between the united states and
north korea north korea isn't supposed
to have access to the global financial
system
in the years that followed the
introduction of u.s sanctions in 2017
their impact became apparent
particularly
on the north korean elites
the price of an apartment in pyongyang
and some of the elite districts fell by
80 percent
we saw more cases of elite defections
we saw that some of the chinese banks
were avoiding business with north
koreans
joint enterprises in places like rasan
were suddenly deserted
there was much much less commerce
visible in dandong which is the border
town
forest laborers were returning home were
unable to pay their
so-called loyally loyalty kickbacks to
the state
there was really a wide range of effects
that were observable one of the
criticisms of economic sanctions is that
like military weapons they can hurt
innocent civilians
north korea is thought to be going
through its worst economic crisis since
the 1990s when famine killed millions of
people
aid agencies like unicef say
international sanctions are hampering
the humanitarian effort to help north
koreans even despite exemptions for
things like food and medical goods
and while ordinary people are suffering
the regime that the sanctions are
supposed to be hurting the most is
finding ways around them i sat on the
u.n panel of experts
to investigate
sanctions of asian north korean
sanctions invasion activity and report
that to the security council north korea
has established relatively effective
sanctions invasion methods and
techniques
so kim jong-un's regime is continuing to
test ballistic missiles of ever
increasing ranges therefore can we say
that the international sanctions have
been a success
if the success is to slow down the rate
of proliferation
uh or to increase the cost premium for
north korea to launder its money they
they have been a limited success
uh in
persuading kim jong-un
that cling to nuclear weapons is a
threat to the stability of the state
and that is the only motive that will
disarm him they have not succeeded
now let's turn to south america
venezuela once the continent's richest
country has also been a major target of
u.s sanctions
the venezuelan government has been
accused of human rights violations of
being involved in narcotics trafficking
financial crimes and what the us calls
insufficient cooperation in the
targeting of terrorism and it's for that
reason it's been the subject of a series
of rounds of sanctions by the us since
2006
but amid months of intense
anti-government protest in venezuela in
2017 with more than a hundred
demonstrators killed as the state
cracked down the u.s ratcheted up
sanctions in a campaign to maximize
pressure on nicolas maduro's government
the u.s cut off venezuela's access to
the american financial system barred
transactions with its state oil company
pede vasa and significantly expanded
personal sanctions against figures
connected to maduro
the goal was regime change but with
maduro's continuing hold over the
country it hasn't worked
there is a theory that the longer
sanctions are in place the less powerful
they become he replaces his relation
with the us
or
other countries
and he tries to
get closer to
the russian federation maybe iran which
is also under sanctions
and they are still there right
and some other countries like that so
they they tend to
uh to build a new group
of
sanctions targeting countries
as long-standing as u.s sanctions
against venezuela have been the u.s
boycott of cuba has been for a lot
longer
it's
half a century more than 50 years since
cuba was
under sanctions in fact the u.s embargo
against cuba marked 60 years this year
it was on the 3rd of february 1962 that
president john f kennedy signed a decree
banning bilateral trade with cuba
penalizing the country over its links
with communist regimes like china and
the soviet union
there was a time when it looked like the
60-year anniversary wouldn't happen in
the last months of his leadership former
president barack obama made a historic
visit to havana
i have come here
to bury the last remnant of the cold war
in the americas but my time here in cuba
renews my hope and my confidence in what
the cuban people will do we can make
this journey as friends and as neighbors
and as family
together
[Music]
but the normalization of u.s cuba
relations was quickly rolled back under
trump who reimposed and widened the
sanctions despite widespread recognition
of their failure to achieve key policy
aims like promoting democracy
maybe that will be the best example to
say that sanctions in the long term
they are losing power and they could
maybe
work
if a country is
whether a democratic
country or moving towards democracy
but in authoritarian regimes
seems like the
situation is different often sanctions
provide particularly one-party
governments with a scapegoat for their
citizens hardships
is
the united nations has said that the u.s
embargo on cuba has cost the country's
economy
130 billion dollars over nearly six
decades that's in line with the island
nation's own estimates let's turn our
attention to another major target for
international sanctions
iran
there is a host of sanctions that has
been put on iran
for more than the past decade
starting with sanctions for human rights
violations individuals which have been
listed and whose whose accounts have
been frozen
to broad
economic sanctions from oil and gas
exports which are restricted to specific
industries like steel or
precious metals
and even the iranian central bank has
been put under sanctions at the height
of the nuclear crisis
leading the way with the sanctions
against iran was once again the united
states the u.s sanctioned over 650
iranian individuals and institutions
under the obama administration that was
before the u.s unilaterally withdrew
from the so-called iran nuclear deal
under president donald trump he
effectively abandoned negotiations with
tehran over its atomic weapons plans in
favor of a much tougher sanctions regime
the trump administration hit another
individuals and institutions with
restrictions
iranian banks were also kicked out of
the swift international banking
messaging system for the second time
something that russian banks are now
having to reckon with the impact of the
increased sanctions regime on iran was
enormous there has been a huge economic
downturn
the
iranian
companies that had to cut business uh
with european ones in particular
made losses they had to redirect their
trade
they incurred cost in order to avoid or
evade sanctions and then there is the
damage that is done to civil society to
a society writ large
people who cannot travel who cannot
visit their relatives um people who have
to do two or three jobs in order to make
a living because the currency has
nosedived
so there is a huge effect all in all
that one can see
however iran has also been able to find
ways around some of the restrictions
it's still managing to export its most
important product
china is iran's biggest customer for oil
in fact it's importing more iranian oil
now than it was before the sanctions
were put in place some 800 000 barrels
per day during january of 2022.
iranian oil has been arriving in china
in recent years marked as coming from
countries like the united arab emirates
oman or malaysia
this is just another example of a
sanctioned country turning to china or
another sanctioned state to find a way
round international restrictions so once
again we have to ask are the sanctions
achieving what they set out to achieve
ironically the iran case where the
nuclear deal was struck
including because of internationally
coordinated sanctions the iran case was
taken
as a good example of how sanctions can
work
now look at what happened after the deal
was struck the united states pull out
without
you know iran giving them reason to do
so
and has imposed its own what is called
maximum pressure regime of sanctions but
in effect taking european companies
along because they had to abide by by
u.s legislation
so what one can see now is a hardening
of the regime
an increase of the nuclear program
precisely in the face of sanctions so
iran doesn't make a good case in favor
of sanctions anymore at this point
you might have noticed a thread through
this video the involvement of the united
states
over recent decades the united states
has established itself as the world's
sanctioner in chief it's deployed the
weapon more often and with greater force
than any other single nation
so why is that after the wars um iraq
and afghanistan
there has been a tendency um in the
united states to
you know lash out uh at whatever um
four enemy uh antagonist they find uh
through sanctions especially financial
sanctions that's because the united
states is at the heart of the financial
system worldwide so if you know someone
is is barred from making dollar
transactions an individual or an
institution then they really can't do
global business so having now looked at
some of the targets of sanctions from
the u.s and from the un the eu and other
nations can we conclude whether
sanctions actually work
research has actually been done into
this the peterson institute for
international economics looked at over
200 cases where sanctions were used it
concluded they were overall at least
partially successful around a third of
the time
34 percent
but the success rates depended greatly
on what a government was trying to
achieve if it was to force through a
modest policy change such as securing
the release of a prisoner the sanctions
had some success more often than not but
if the aim was something larger like
disrupting a military adventure like
russia invading ukraine the success rate
was a lot lower
sanctions can work very well if you're
doing
a few things right number one you have
to enforce them
number two i and i think this is the
lesson of cuba you can't do it
unilaterally you need to do it in
concert with partners
and number three you have to really aim
at goals the main
principle is that they can work in the
short run i mean if they're imposed
quickly swiftly and harshly
um then they might work
because of
they because of them having a real
effect an immediate effect
the longer they last um the less likely
they are to be successful
so will the short sharp shock of the
sanctions imposed on russia be enough to
change president putin's military
ambitions
well there is cause for hope what we
have seen
uh recently with russia and the ukraine
is in fact a well-coordinated
multilateral international
coalition-based strategy to force
russia through economic pressure
to
change its behavior this is exactly what
we should have done years ago in north
korea the lessons learned from sanctions
past include the fact that little is
achieved with sanctions alone sanctions
are more symbolic
than effective
they send a strong message right you are
on the wrong path
uh you have to you have to reverse
course
but
only sanctions
no if you go into it believing that you
know sanctions is just one side of the
core it's just one tool in your toolbox
and that you still need to achieve
diploma you know your the outcomes
through through diplomacy but this is
just your source of leverage
i think that uh you can achieve a far
higher success rate and i think that
you know the us and
its allies would be wise to
approach sanctions
from that perspective
we've heard sanctions described as one
step short of war
but many of us are hoping the sanctions
against russia can walk ukraine back to
a state of peace
and that's all from this edition of
business beyond for more from us why not
check out our playlist perhaps start
with our video about the impact of
inflation around the world at the moment
remember to hit like and subscribe if
you've enjoyed what you've seen until
next time
take
[Music]
you